i just remember
thinking please god please
i hope it's not broken
i don't know how that ended
amber heard and johnny depp issued
statements slamming each other following
the actress's explosive testimony depp's
team calling it the performance of her
life with her camp calling his behavior
pitiful
the next thing i remember
always been over um
backwards
on the bar meaning my chest was up
i was staring at the blue lights and
my
chest
on this
my back was on the
countertops
and i
thought he was punching me
depp is suing his ex-wife for defamation
over an op-ed the 36-year-old actress
wrote in 2018 for the washington post
where she alleged she was the victim of
domestic violence
and on thursday hurd took the stand
breaking down in tears recalling details
of the alleged abuse she says she
experienced at the hands of the
58-year-old actor we got an argument in
the hotel room
and i
i said i i don't remember what i said to
him but i
said something snotty to to to him
that provoked him it provoked him um
and when i walked
into the hallway
he grabbed me by the arm and slammed me
up against the
hallway wall and i kind of struggled
with him tried to push him off of me and
i managed to get out of his grasp
enough to
take a few steps and kind of i kind of
curved around and went into the closet
now in a statement to et a spokesperson
for the pirates of the caribbean star
accuses herd of changing her story with
new and convenient details adding that
depp's recollections have remained
exactly the same throughout the six
painful years since her first
allegations were made quote his truth
the truth is the same no matter the
environment in which it has been
presented the statement goes on to say
that the upcoming cross-examination from
depp's lawyers will be most telling and
will highlight the many fallacies they
claim she has attempted to pass off as
fact in response a spokesperson for the
aquaman star slams depp accusing him of
attacking the victim and refusing to
take responsibility for his own conduct
quote if mr depp was truly innocent why
has he repeatedly apologized to miss
heard and promised to put the monster
away for good
he begged me to forgive him that was the
last time
the monster will never come back monster
will never come back the spokesperson
adds that one of herd's disappointments
is her ex's inability to distinguish
fact from fiction and they call him out
for not having the fortitude or courage
to even look at misheard before pointing
out that instead he doodles and snickers
of course that's a reference to this
moment during the trial where the actor
was seen drawing a portrait on a post-it
and showing it to his lawyer
mr depp's behavior in this trial has
been as pitiful as it was in their
marriage
the former couple married in 2015 and
split in may 2016 when heard sought a
domestic violence restraining order
against him accusing him of abusing her
depp denied the claims and the two
settled their divorce out of court in
august 2016.
now depp is suing herd for defamation
saying that 2018 op-ed tarnished his
reputation and ruined his career even
though she never mentioned him by name
in the article mr depp how did you feel
when you learned that
you were being dropped from the pirates
of the caribbean franchise i didn't
quite understand how
that after that long relationship and
quite a successful
relationship certainly for disney but
suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent
testimony will resume on monday may 16th
you